das ist wirklich der absolute hammer
wissenschaftler haben womöglich die
fehlende verbindung zwischen
quantentheorie und relativitätstheorie
gefunden dabei ist es eigentlich super
wimpel und selbst ein laie hätte auf die
idee kommen können ihnen nicht
aufgefallen
das ist eine parallele zu den
verschränkten teilchen der quantenphysik
in der relativitätstheorie gibt
wurmlöcher wir könnten auch im
übertragenen sinn eine verbindung
zwischen den beiden theorien herstellen
jetzt also ein paar mind blowing fakten
zur verbindung zwischen
relativitätstheorie und quantentheorie
in klicks und seien sie herzlich
willkommen
es ist ja das riesenthema der physik wie
kriegen wir nur quantenphysik und
relativitätstheorie zusammen seit 100
jahren weisen sich die physiker daran
die zähne aus und ich hätte nie im leben
gedacht dass jetzt schon erste
verbindungen gefunden werden könnten
aber genau das scheint der fall zu sein
professor juan mata zehner von der
amerikanischen princeton university hat
ein gedankenexperiment angestellt und
ist auf verblüffende lösung gekommen
seine überlegung sind echt so simpel da
hätt machen eigentlich selbst drauf
kommen können na ja fast leihen würden
dann leider die mittel fehlen die
hypothesen weiter zu überprüfen und das
hat jetzt hohe alter fehler gemacht und
die konsequenzen werfen unser weltbild
ziemlich durcheinander e-mails simpel
und einfach aufgefallen dass bohrlöcher
wie wie ein stein und roten als
theoretische konstrukte berechnet hatten
die gleichen eigenschaften wie
verschränkte teilchen in der
quantenphysik haben beide verbinden raum
und zeit indem sie obwohl sie sich an
verschiedenen orten befinden direkt
miteinander verbunden sind also
bohrlöcher verbinden jetzt zwei schwarze
löcher sind abkürzung in der raumzeit
und verschränkte teilchen verhalten sich
genauso wie ihr zwilling auch wenn er
sich weit weg an einem anderen ort im
universum befindet was china vermutet
dass das zwei seiten der gleichen
medaille darstellen können beides wären
demnach genau das gleiche nur in einem
anderen maßstab
das kuriose auch einstein untersuchte
beides zusammen mit seinem kollegen
nelson großen entwickelte er die
bedingungen für wurmlöcher die einstein
rosen brücken und er untersuchte auf
verschränkte teilchen in einem
gedankenexperiment mit rosen und einem
weiteren kollegen boris preuss gibt für
einstein war es aber eine spukhafte
fernwirkung diese verschränkten teilchen
wurmlöcher widersprachen gemäss einzeln
aber nicht der relativitätstheorie
verschränkte teilchen eben schon das
wurmlöcher und verschränkte teilchen wie
so ähnlich sind fielen damals gar nicht
auf das hat man ja jetzt nachgeholt und
weitergeführt in seinen gedanken
experiment hat er sich einfach zwei
schwarze löcher aus verschränkten
teilchen vorgestellt in jedem schwarzen
loch sind also teilchen die mit den
teilchen in einem anderen schwarzen loch
verschränkt sind und siehe da was
entsteht wenn ein wurmloch
und diese idee löst noch ein paar andere
probleme so würden nach einer arbeit von
forschern der university of california
durch die hawking strahlung am
ereignisort gewaltige energien
freigesetzt werden er würde brennen wäre
das schwarze loch aber durch ein
wurmloch mit einem anderen system
verknüpft würde dass einige probleme mit
dieser these lügen und weiser 10 er geht
noch weiter wir stellen die krümmung der
raumzeit der gern hat eine vertiefung
einer fläche da ich ab dass er hier auf
klick zum jahr mit einem betttuch
gezeigt große massen die raumzeit als
würden sie in einem gespannten tuch
liegen in dem sie eine vertiefung
erzeugen wir hier auf der erde werden
durch diese vertiefung durch diese
krümmung der raumzeit die kavitation auf
die erde gezogen meiner fehler hat jetzt
eine idee für dieses tuch er spekuliert
ob nicht diese verschränkung und
wurmlöcher schäden sind die die fläche
bilden demnach würde die raumzeit nicht
einfach so existieren sondern wäre ein
effektiver phänomene
er kann sich vorstellen dass auf diese
weise relativitätstheorie und
quantenmechanik endlich vereinigt werden
könnten
wahnsinn das war jetzt echt ne packung
theoretisch bewegt demnächst geht es
dazu genau dazu hier weiter es gibt
nämlich weitere überlegungen zur auszeit
die auch absolut mein borken sind wenn
er das video nicht verpassen wollte
dadurch mehr hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesslich die einen auf die glocke zu
geben damit er auch wirklich nichts
verpasst hier geht es weiter mit der
relativitätstheorie einfach draufklicken
das video ist wirklich ziemlich leicht
verständlich und ihr werdet hoffentlich
schlauer also ansonsten bedanken